[Musique]
oh mon dieu, nous avons des raisons de croire que
lucious pourrait être sur la propriété
Oh les gars qu'est-ce que c'était qu'est-ce que c'était
[Musique]
vous faites des farces vous mourez
d'envie d'avoir un nouvel assistant vous allez être la
sécurité  garde vous sentez-vous à l'aise
avec la traduction de ce qu'il y a sur le
sarcophage quand il arrive assurez-vous que
rien de mal n'arrive pour sauver votre gorge
cet ours bouge hmm
faisons une autre frayeur êtes-vous cool
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] les
gars je sais ce qui se passe vous êtes sur
mon  Prank Show Pranking Powder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes absolument pour tout,
allons-y